so hi everyone my name is Varun I work
as a JavaScript developer at a company
called League in Toronto Canada and in
my spare time I build a little
interactive animations and sometimes
write about the the math behind them and
the the process behind them and that's
sort of what I want to focus on today I
want to talk about three concepts these
are not the three most important
concepts but they just happen to be
three concepts that I come across a lot
in my work and I just want to share that
the theory behind them and talk about
some of the applications when it comes
to animating on the web so starting with
polar coordinates going into
oscillations and then finally solving
triangles so coordinate systems are a
tool that you might be familiar with
they're allow us to figure out the
position of something in two-dimensional
and three-dimensional space the one that
you've probably likely used is the
Cartesian coordinate system this is used
by if you're working with CSS transforms
or HTML canvas WebGL or just about any
graphics tool out in the market and the
way this works is you locate the
position of something in terms of X or Y
that is the distance from the y-axis or
the distance from the x-axis and this
works quite nicely allows you to do just
about anything that you want there are
however other options available to us
and one of them is the polar coordinate
system and in the polar coordinate
system you think about locations not in
terms of x and y but in terms of radius
and theta where radius is the distance
from the origin and theta is the angle
so what does that mean
if I focus more on this image here let's
say we were trying to locate the
position of the point P and always the
origin of our of our 2d space here and
if I draw a line from o to P the length
of that line is the radius and the angle
is the angle that line mates from the x
axis so why would you want to do this
well in some cases think
thing about our geometry in terms of
polar coordinates makes our life really
easy and allows us to do things which
otherwise might be quite hard with
Cartesian coordinates an example of that
is to build patterns such as these these
are known as polar patterns and even
animate them so to do something like
this you can use polar coordinates and
if I break down that shape what it looks
like is essentially its layers of
concentric circles where on each circle
you're placing these dots evenly around
the circle so that at the outermost
circle you can set the value for the
radius coordinate sorry the radius part
of the coordinate to be the same and the
only thing you're changing is the angle
so the first one starts at 0 degrees
then 30 degrees 60 degrees and so on and
you can complete the whole circle and
then to generate that pulsing motion all
you're doing is animating the the radius
value and that causes the whole thing to
scale down and scale back up and this
little trick allows you to do some
really interesting work you can choose
how you place things around on that
circle you can evenly space them out or
offset them slightly and when it comes
to animation you can choose to animate
the radius and that gives you the
pulsing effect or you can animate the
the theta value which gives you more of
the rotational effect like the example
in the bottom right hand corner there we
can also use polar coordinates to
generate dynamically generate polygons
and specifically regular polygons so a
regular polygon is just a polygon where
all of the sides have the same length
and that particular shape has a special
property which is that the vertices were
for the polygons are all on the same are
all essentially evenly spaced out on a
circle so much like the the polar
pattern I showed the only difference is
you end up joining them with a line and
that that's what gives you the shape so
to locate the position of these vertices
the first one starts at theta of zero
and that and the second one starts at
theta of a particular angle times the
index and that angle is the number of
sites at the polygon
sorry 360 degrees divided by the number
of sites that the polygon has so the
first index will be at 0 times ank that
angle the second one at one time set
angle the third one at two times that
angle and so on and this allows us to
generate the list of points of a regular
polygon really easily but then if you
want to use them in an SVG path or
canvas you have to then convert it back
to Cartesian coordinates to actually
render it onto the screen and the way
you can do that is by using this formula
where the x value of the coordinate is
radius times cos of theta and the y
value is radius times sine of theta so
in JavaScript code that looks something
like this I have a little function here
that is used to generate the the
vertices of a polygon it takes in two
variables the number of sides that this
polygon has and the radius which sort of
controls how big or small this polygon
would be and then the first thing we do
is calculate the angle so 360 divided by
the count then we create a placeholder
for all of the vertices by using a
little utility that spits out an array
that has values 0 1 2 all the way up to
the number of sides that you specified
and then we map over this array to
generate the coordinate where theta is
angle times the index of that vertex and
the radius is whatever radius you pass
in and one thing to keep in mind here is
when it comes to humans are especially
me thinking about angles in terms of
degrees is really nice and makes my life
easier but when it comes to writing code
pretty much every single time you're
going to have to convert that value into
radians so that's what I'm doing here
I'm calculating the angle in terms of
360 degrees but then converting it into
radians and saving that as my value and
then once again to use this to render
something I can use the X and y formula
that I left out there so why would you
want to do something like this if you're
generating your geometry dynamically you
can connect it
a user input so in this case I used an
example that was originally created by
Chris Gannon and he created this really
amazing hexagon that's being animated
and it was built out to be just a
hexagon so I modified this to replace it
with dynamically generated geometry and
wired it up to a couple of sliders so
with the radius slider I can sort of
control how big or small the shape is
and then with the other side the other
slider that controls the number of sides
I can sort of change what shape is being
generated so it's the same CSS code
that's being used to render the
animation but I'm applying it to
different different geometry on the page
and you don't have to connected connect
this to sliders you can use any kind of
data or any kind of user input to add a
little bit of dynamic animation to your
page another example is I made this demo
a couple years ago we're using the same
same polygon generator to spit out these
shapes that look like sort of gems and
then wired it up to dynamic lighting
where the cursor controls where the the
location of lighting is it's really
basic tuned shading style lighting and
because this is built with SVG sliced it
up into different parts and each part is
just given a different color which
simulates this lighting and the reason I
can do this is because I'm generating
that geometry dynamically I can sort of
figure out and break it out into the
different faces and color them
accordingly and some more examples that
I've seen out in on the internet someone
actually built out a animation loader
using exactly the same polar coordinate
pattern and then coder UPS has this had
this fantastic article a few weeks ago
that talked about building view page
transitions and the shapes that they
built out were these organically looking
blobs and again they used polar
coordinates to generate those shapes so
moving on to waves and oscillations so
there's this function that you're
probably all aware of called sine
that takes in an angle value and spits
out a value that is somewhere between
minus 1 and 1 so as you give it
different angle values it generates this
wave-like pattern which looks quite
boring but allows you to do some really
interesting stuff so these are all gifs
created by an artist named Dave white
who also goes by the name B's and BOM I
really like his work and one thing
you'll notice is he uses this idea of
oscillations quite a lot in his work and
he uses them to drive all kinds of
things the location of something the
scale of something or even the scale
size color and so on so let's look at
how we would do something like this
sorry alright so here I have a little
setup that demonstrates how to use sign
to drive some kind of animation in
animation loop context so I start by
declaring a variable called theta this
is going to be the angle that we change
in our animation loop set it as with an
initial value of let's say zero and then
in my animation loop I'm simply
incrementing that theta with whatever
value you choose the larger that number
will be the faster the animation will be
the smaller that number the slower the
animation will be and again remember
this is in radians and not degrees and
then you can apply that theta to the
sine function in JavaScript and then use
that to drive different parts of your
application for example if I multiply
the output of that sine function to the
scale that gives you this pulsing effect
if I use that sine function to control
the x-coordinate I can make something
oscillate around a point so in this case
it's a slightly different format you
start with some basic value oh sorry the
base value of the x-coordinate that's
the start value and then to that you add
the sine function times some amplitude
and in this case I'm picking 300 pixels
and that amplitude controls how far the
ball is going to move around the X so
again the larger the amplitude the
further it'll go the smaller the closer
you'll stay and then lastly you can also
use it to rotate things about points so
going back to that polar coordinates
idea again this time I'm using the same
sine function actually sine n cos in
this case they're both kind of related
to each other to calculate the x and y
coordinates and since I want to rotate
this about a point I also specify the
initial values in terms of the center of
rotation so you're you're changing the
place on the circle that this point
appears by changing the theta value but
then you can translate in into 2d space
by adding Center X or Center Y to that
value and this is sort of the starting
point you can combine sine and costs to
create other kinds of motion which isn't
just that static just not just a one
waveform motion if you combine them you
could come up with some really really
interesting
eating's and this is sort of a more
real-world example where someone used
exactly that concept to rotate this
spaceship around the moon in this case
it was done using JavaScript but you can
do it that you can do the same thing
with CSS animation if you want so going
back to Dave White's work again one
thing you'll notice is in most of its
work everything doesn't move at the same
same time things look a lot better the
animations look a lot more organic when
things have a slightly slightly delayed
motion to them so you can see each one
of these circles they're following the
same path or the same amount of motion
but it just happens with offsets to each
other so the way you can do that is
let's say start with this example of a
ball which is bobbing up and down using
that sine function and the initial value
that we gave to this the initial theta
value was set to zero you add another
ball but this time you give it an
initial value of 0.2 so there's a slight
offset to it and you can see that
already there's a slightly more
interesting motion or in my opinion
slightly more interesting ocean and as
you can see each time you add a ball and
give it a slightly larger offset you can
create this nice wave-like pattern where
each ball is moving in a wave-like
motion but then together they're follow
they're creating a more complex motion
and then of course you can add layers to
it to create even more interesting
animations and the last topic I want to
cover today is solving triangles so this
is one of those things that once you
once you learn about this you you see it
everywhere so I almost encountered this
in just about every piece of animation I
ever built and really what this talks
about is you have some information about
a triangle and you want to use that to
figure out all the other properties of
that triangle so for example that might
be you know two sides the length of two
sides
you want to figure out the angle or you
know two angles and you want to figure
out the size of the the length of the
sides so I'll start with the the most
straightforward case which is for a
right triangle so a right triangle is
simply a triangle where one of the
angles is 90 degrees so in this case you
might end up in that same scenario where
you know the lengths of two of the sides
and you want to figure out one of the
angles or vice versa so for this I'm
going to ask you to go back to high
school and you might remember this
mnemonic device
sohcahtoa from your math classes
especially the trigonometric part of it
and you might also remember these
formulas that you encountered that's
exactly what you're going to be using
here so back in high school when you
learn that math class and you were
wondering why on earth would I ever need
to know trigonometry
the answer is animation that's the only
time you ever need it so in this case
for example if we wanted to calculate
the value of theta and I knew two of the
sides I can use one of those formulas
for example the are tangent or R cosine
or sine pham formulas to figure out the
value of theta so let's look at some
examples where this came in handy this
is an example from the p5.js website
they have a little eye tracking
animation so these eyes follow the mouse
cursor here which is the blue dot that
you see and really the way this is done
is the little black circle inside the
white circle you're changing the theta
value so again going back to polar
coordinates all you're doing is you're
changing the angle where this which
decides where the circle ends up in this
and the larger white circle so this is
sort of the triangle that we're forming
here since I'm building this animation I
know the the location of the mouse
cursor and I know the location of the
eye so that means I know the horizontal
distance between those two points that's
one side of the triangle I also know the
vertical distance between those two
points so that's the the second side so
using that arc tangent formula I can go
back and calculate the theta value and
then use that data value
to render out my animation under another
example in this case this is something
that I didn't really have to do in code
but just had to do it by hand or using a
calculator before building out my
animation so to do this it's again using
an SVG animation where the circle is
breaking up into two parts so I kind of
know the ratio that I want to break the
circle apart in but to draw those two
parts separately I have to use the SVG
arc command and to use the SVG art
command I need to know the exact
location for the those two points which
is going to be this starting at the end
point of the arc and then simply choose
whether I draw the larger side of the
arc or the smaller side so again let's
see let's find that triangle I know the
distance between the center of the
circle and those points is just the
radius of the circle one of the angles
is again 90 degrees so we can go back to
using those trigonometry formulas and
then lastly I knew the length of that
little part there because I knew the
ratios that I wanted to split up the
circle in so again using that
information I can I can calculate the
angle and going back to polar
coordinates use it to locate the the two
points and break up the circle into two
arcs so going beyond by triangles in a
more generic use case where you're not
you're working with a triangle that's
not a right triangle in order to solve
that triangle you need slightly more
information so with a right triangle you
just need two pieces of information for
all other kinds of triangles you need at
least three pieces of information so
whether that's three sides or two sides
at an angle or two angles an aside any
of those work and in that scenario you
can use a formula called law of cosines
there similarly something called law of
cost law of sine which looks a lot
similar you can use either or so in this
case you can pick and choose which sites
that you have and which angles you have
and apply to this formula and figure out
all of the other information of the
triangle so let's look at an example
where I use this so a few months ago I
built this animation which essentially
it's using a generative graphic concept
known as metabolic metabolic fat which
meant having to do a lot of math to
figure out how to draw this and what it
comes down to is essentially there are
two circles and then a little white
connector that sort of allows you to
mimic this blobby
shape to it I won't go into all the
details of how this happened I have a
link to a blog post down there that goes
into that but I want to focus on one
specific part so one of the steps in
order to do this was to figure out these
two angles u1 and u2 and these angles
are formed by three point by a triangle
consisting of three points which are the
two centers of the circle and the point
where the two circles intersect so again
I kind of know two sides because there
are the radius of the two circles and
the third side is simply the distance
between the two circles and since I'm
animating these and I'm moving these
things around I know the location of
those two circles that's where the
center's are so I can calculate that
distance and then apply to that law of
cosines formula to figure out the value
for u1 and u2 and be able to figure out
how to draw that connector so I just
want to end by sharing a little resource
so when I was in first learning
programming I learned it through a
language called processing and there's a
book that was that came out when I was
in school called generative design
because I'm in Austria I'm not even
going to attempt to pronounce the German
name here and be sure it but it was a
really amazing resource that goes into a
lot of these mathematical concepts but
and I had a lot of code snippets that
showed you how to do these things with
processing well they're coming out with
a new version later this year which is
built for p5.js so is more to JavaScript
and more
the web the book comes out in a few
months but for now they actually have a
resource up which has a lot of the the
animation examples and which are
interactive and all the code samples
available for you which you can use and
actually see start playing around with
it and learning a lot of these
techniques that are covered here and
that's everything I had thank you
[Applause]
[Music]